William: Hi Corey, I'm Bill Brody I'm the
president of the John Hopkins University in
Baltimore Maryland in the United States
I want to thank you for your very moving video
showing the pictures of wanton destruction
from war and various forms of internal conflict.
I think the one thing that I would like to
convince our leaders of around the world is
to learn the power of non-violent resistance
like Martin Luther King in the United States
did so profoundly.
Or Muhatma Ghandi did in India
If we could convince our leaders that whenever
they use force there's countervailing force
and wanton destruction of innocent civilians
and bystanders.
That war is never the way to go.
And we need to push more towards peaceful
resistance.
Thank you so much for your video and good
luck and let's work together on this.